in the four cases as follows; first, if X, Y equals zero, zero, then these are the probabilities
of the various measurement outcomes, and you have to either think back or look back at the analysis
that we just went through to conclude that using our formula.
Over here, we can see the
different state vectors drawn as they were before, and the color coding here
is that blue corresponds
to the outcome zero and red
corresponds to the outcome one.
You can see that the angle
between the blue vectors and the angle between the red
vectors is relatively small,
it's pi over eight in both cases, so the cosine is relatively large, and that means that the
probability that the two outcomes
are equal is relatively large.
In the case that X, Y equals zero, one, it's a similar situation, the
angles between the vectors having the same color is small,
so the probability of
equal outcomes is again, relatively large.
The third case is similar, and in the fourth case
when X, Y equals one, one, something interesting happens,
this time, just by the way,
these vectors have been chosen, we see that the angles between
vectors having the same color
are relatively large, and specifically the angles are three times
pi over eight in both cases.
This means that the probability
that the measurement outcomes is equal is relatively small, but this is the one case
in which Alice and Bob win
when their answers disagree,
so it's what we want.
Once again, here are the vectors: when X, Y equals zero, zero,
when Xx, Y equals zero, one,
when X, Y equals one, zero,
and when X, Y equals one, one.
And perhaps this geometric
picture is helpful in building some intuition
for how this strategy works
and why these various angles were chosen in the way that they were.
To finish off the lesson, I'll make a few brief
remarks about the CHSH game.
First, as I've already mentioned, this example isn't always
described as a game.
In the physics community, for instance, it's more common that
the example is described simply as an experiment rather than a game
and Alice and Bob are
viewed as being detectors rather than players.
The basic idea of an experiment like this where entanglement leads
to statistical results that are inconsistent with
any classical description
or more generally any
theory based on so-called local hidden variables,
is due to John Bell, the namesake of the Bell states,
and so people often refer
to experiments of this sort as Bell tests.
Sometimes people also
refer to Bell's theorem, which can be formulated in different ways, but it basically says
that quantum mechanics
is not compatible with so-called local hidden variable theories.
The CHSH game or inequality is essentially a very nice and clean
example of a Bell test,
and you can think about
this example as a proof or a demonstration of Bell's theorem.
The second remark is that the CHSH game offers us one way to experimentally test that the theory of quantum information
is an accurate theory. We can actually set up experiments that implement the CHSH game,
including the sort of
strategy based on entanglement that I had just described, and
see if it works, and it does.
This provides us with a
high degree of confidence that entanglement is real, and unlike the perhaps
vague or poetic ways
that we try to come up with
to explain entanglement, the CHSH game or experiment
gives us a concrete
and testable way to observe entanglement.
If that sounds important,
it's because it is, and the 2022 Nobel Prize
in physics acknowledges exactly this.
The prize was awarded to
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, who is the C in CHSH, and Anton Zeilinger
for experiments with entangled photons that established the violation
of Bell inequalities, or in other words, that
showed that quantum strategies
of the sort that I described actually work and outperform classical strategies.
And if you're interested in
learning more about this, I encourage you to check out
the video on Bells Theorem by my colleague Olivia Lanes,
right here on the Qiskit YouTube channel.
And finally, the topic of
non-local games more generally is truly fascinating, and it's
an active area of research
that brings together
physics, computer science, and pure mathematics and there are still many
interesting questions
about non-local games that
remain unanswered to this day.
And that is the end of lesson four, as well as the end of
unit one of the series on the Basics of Quantum Information.
The first lesson explained
how quantum information works for single systems in isolation, and the second lesson explained
how quantum information
works for multiple systems,
which pretty naturally emerges from how it works for single systems.